well there's some progress for women but
obviously we do not have enough progress
women do not have enough rights and
those rights that we have we have to
work to enforce and for example we are
coming up to the 90th anniversary of
women's winning the right to vote that's
a 19th amendment the addition of the
19th amendment suffrage to the United
States Constitution August 26 1920 and
we do not yet enjoy the passage of the
Equal Rights Amendment to the United
States Constitution which we have been
working to win ever since Ellis Paul
proposed it in 1923 so in other words it
has taken us all these years and it's
still even though we have a Democratic
Congress not coming out of the Congress
well we almost wanted some years ago
before that there was a time limitation
passed on the Equal Rights Amendment
which had been passed for any other
amendment and so we were not able to see
succeed in getting it added at that time
as an amendment so we need to have more
activism to win the ER a now because all
it says is that equality of rights under
the law shall not be denied or abridged
by the United States or by any State on
account of gender or an account of sex
and those simple words should be part of
our Constitution because without it we
do not enjoy first class citizenship we
do not enjoy all the legal rights and
privileges that men enjoy and we often
say in the women's movement men their
rights and nothing more women their
rights and nothing less so we do need to
pass that
I think there are laws and there are
regulations and a family law is an area
which is just ripe with problems and
very much in need of improvement all
kinds of issues child support for
example most mothers are awarded an
inadequate amount of child support if
they are awarded any child support at
all not sufficient to support the child
and that's what this is all about and
the enforcement of child support is
relatively poor in this country and the
net effect of that is that it is the
inability to collect child support or an
adequate amount of child support that is
the number one reason that women
millions of them are forced on to
welfare rolls and into lives of poverty
forced to receive aid to families with
dependent children afdc because of the
inadequacy of child support laws and the
inadequacy of the enforcement of those
laws and most of those who have an order
for child support are women because
generally is the mother taking care of
the child so it has an adverse impact on
women and children but while there are
some steps to do something about it and
to leave the burden from these mothers
and from the taxpayers and place the
responsibility where it belongs on the
non-custodial parent namely the father
there's still too many deadbeat dads and
really not a real commitment from the
system to make major improvements so
that is just one area but there are many
other areas as well that need
improvement in employment in child
sexual abuse rape sexual harassment
there's just many many changes that need
to be made in the law so the bottom line
is we are still making her story we
still are fighting to win changes and so
we need more women elected to office
feminist women we need them
as representatives in our state
legislature we need them at all levels
of power in the federal government we
often say a woman's places in the house
the House of Representatives now we say
it's also in the house the White House
and in the United States Senate where we
still do not have equal representation
of women just have a small percent of
all United States senators and women so
and we need more women as judges and on
boards commissions and agencies so in
employment we need more women at the top
levels there's stole the glass ceiling
where women can see to the top in
business but often can't make it through
the glass ceiling which prevents them
getting to the top glass ceiling is
another way of saying women are still
being discriminated against on account
of their gender here's the good news
women are fighting back through lawsuits
and they're winning but unfortunately
sometimes women say to me well why do I
have to fight for my rights I thought I
had them well you don't have them unless
you stand up and enforce those rights so
we're alike private attorney generals in
our law firm all red morocco and
goldberg where i've been practicing for
35 years as a partner as a founding
partner of the law firm and you know we
take these rights seriously they are
meant for the protection of our clients
and women everywhere